bonjour à tous j'espère que vous allez
bien moi je vous aurais vérité je suis
en ultra gueule de bois entre ça et ma
dernière vidéo vous devez vous dire ce
mec est clairement alcoolique oh non
pas vous rêve vous avez cliqué sur cette
miniature avec une bague dessus en vous
demandant va-t-il se marier eh bien
écoutez je ne sais pas encore car cette
miniature était 100% foot à cliquer
cette vidéo parle clairement d'autres
choses je vais vous annoncer quelque
chose d'extraordinaire un truc tout
nouveau pour moi est totalement génial
je vous explique ça fait des années
maintenant que je m'amuse régulièrement
à gribouiller des petites blagues en
dessin que je fais juste pour mon
plaisir vous êtes pu le voir par exemple
dans le dvd non spectacle ou non condroz
my life et souvent je garde ses dessins
pour moi et puis plus récemment je me
suis mis à les mettre un peu sur
instagram et là surprise ça nous a
vraiment plu à tel point que mes dessins
ont commencé à récolter plus de like que
des photos de moi donc gelé à la fois
bien pris et mal pris c'est très chaud
beaucoup d'entre vous ont suggéré l'idée
d'en faire un livre au début j'ai fait
non ça m'a un peu trotter dans la tête
pendant des semaines des mois et au bout
d'un moment je me suis dit et pourquoi
pas après énormément de temps investi et
de passion et de cliff évidemment je
suis très fier de vous annoncer que je
sors aujourd'hui précisément mon premier
livre de dessins qui s'intitule tout
simplement mes dessins
j'ai pas mal réfléchi au titre on dirait
pas comme ça mais au moins on capte ses
deux dents qu'il ya mes dessins alors ne
partez pas je sais ce que vous vous
dites tiens encore un énième youtuber
qui nous sort une énième d'aidé randonne
dont on a rien à [ __ ] oui mais non et
je vous dit pourquoi déjà c'est pas une
bd ni un roman ni des stries c'est plein
d'idées que je trouve ma rente que j'ai
mis en dessin avec mon style disons
minimaliste je me suis amusé parfois sur
papier parfois sur l'ipad avec photoshop
bref je me suis juste éclaté en fait une
page égale une idée rien ne se suivent
c'est comme dans ma tête en fait c'est
le bordel alors c'est très varié et des
dessins sur le quotidien sur notre
époque sur la vie en général
il ya des remarques un peu satirique des
objets des schémas encore des objets des
parodies de marque dépenser un peu
poétique encore encore des objets et
plein de trucs très très très différents
c'est difficile à définir parce que
finalement chaque page est un nouveau
concept je vous entends quelques-uns
mais évidemment les meilleurs je vous
laisse les découvrir directement dans le
livre ce bouquin j'ai entièrement pensé
écrit dessiné avec amour j'ai adoré le
faire donc je suis vraiment trop trop
content car ce n'est pas un vulgaire
produit marketing je vous jure si je les
fais c'est vraiment parce que j'en avais
envie pour nous plaisir parfois vous y
verrez un petit personnage que je fais
régulièrement une sorte de mini moi en
fait qu'elle ait tous nous pu
s'identifier
non excusez moi mais tu fais ce bouquin
parce qu'il a plus d'idées en fait
bah là en l'occurence j'ai eu 2 130
trois idées donc c'est quand même plus
que pas d'idée quand même c'est beaucoup
plus quand tu dis dessin minimaliste
c'est pour pas dire que tu dessines
comme un enfant de 5 ans parce que même
mon petit frère de 5 ans il fait mieux
il ya plein d'artistes dans le monde
depuis toujours qu'ils sont connus pour
leur style de dessin plutôt minimaliste
et puis tu sais quoi mon petit style de
dessin et ben j'en suis très fier et je
t'en as donc tu te prends pour un
artiste non c'est parce que je voulais
dire mais un donc c'est un livre de
blagues au caire j'imagine que des
blagues racistes
bien essayé mais non et sinon est ce que
au lieu de dire un ramassis de conneries
tu voudrais pas en fait resté un tout
petit peu en avance c'est à dire
je suis trop content de ce projet cette
aventure j'ai beaucoup de chance d'avoir
pu le faire je remercie évidemment
michel lafon de m'avoir fait confiance
sur ce projet et je vous montre le petit
moment où je les découvrir les premiers
exemplaires
les gars je suis avec nico qui a fait
une énorme dinguerie c'est à dire qu'il
a fait une surprise
[Musique]
mais pippa qui manque une jambe il
paraissait manquer qu'il est beaucoup
mieux comme ça
comme un des samoa gravée sur sa peau
une délicieuse de plus direction un
petit pote gloria t'as fait quoi là la
tuque c'était un livre de coloriage
oisiens franck c'est le tien cela parce
que on peut plus le vendre
[Musique]
merci marc a coûté c'était une vidéo
100% autopromo j'en suis conscient mais
c'est ma chaîne donc je me permets de
temps en temps voilà j'ai adoré faire ça
j'ai hâte que vous puissiez le découvrir
et les inventeurs partout
[Musique]
je vous mets un petit lien dans la
description pour acheter le livre
directement bonne lecture
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]